[MUSIC PLAYING]
JESSICA HARROP: Hi, I'm Jessica.
And I'm going to show you
a chemical demonstration
that I like to call
let's drink to that.
Now performing chemistry
demos is hard work.
And MIT's Dr. John Dolhun--
here he is-- is thirsty.
Let's watch him and
his assistant Barry
at the Cambridge
Science Festival.
[WHOOSH]
BARRY KRIEGSMAN: Here
you've got some Fiji Water,
but I figured you could
try some of, I don't know,
my personal favorite
tap water as well.
I don't know.
JOHN DOLHUN: I think I'm going
to stick with the Fiji water.
BARRY KRIEGSMAN: You're
going to stick with that?
OK, that's fine.
Well, if you'd like
I could treat you
to something a little better.
I don't know.
What would you imagine?
What it would like
to drink right now?
JOHN DOLHUN: A glass of wine.
BARRY KRIEGSMAN: A glass
of wine, absolutely.
JOHN DOLHUN: Do you have a list?
Wine list?
BARRY KRIEGSMAN: Oh, yeah.
JOHN DOLHUN: Oh, you do have?
BARRY KRIEGSMAN: Oh.
JOHN DOLHUN: You
left me a wine list.
BARRY KRIEGSMAN: Is there
one in particular you'd like?
JOHN DOLHUN: Actually, you
have a cabernet on there,
$15 a glass though, Barry.
BARRY KRIEGSMAN: OK,
I got it just for you.
So one cabernet.
JOHN DOLHUN: That's
a nice light wine.
BARRY KRIEGSMAN: There you go.
JOHN DOLHUN: Has a
little color in it.
Nice.
[WHOOSH]
JESSICA HARROP: So Barry
turned water into wine.
In our video recording
of the experiment,
the wine doesn't look
very red, but you
can see the red color forming
at the bottom of the glass.
He started with a
clear, colorless liquid
that looks like water
but that actually
contains sodium carbonate.
Now, in water, sodium
carbonate breaks apart
into CO32 minus, HCO3
minus, and OH minus.
To go from water to wine, Barry
poured this sodium carbonate
solution into a wine
glass that contained
a little bit of the
indicator phenolphthalein.
In acidic solutions,
phenolphthalein is colorless.
But in basic solutions,
it's dark pink.
So here's a pH scale.
At around 8 on the pH scale,
phenolphthalein turns pink.
So it goes from acidic to basic.
And the OH ions in Barry's
fake water make it basic,
so the indicator turns pink.
So when mixed with
phenolphthalein,
the sodium carbonate
looks like wine.
Now, let's see
what happens next.
[WHOOSH]
BARRY KRIEGSMAN: I have my own
favorite drink, milk, you know.
It goes well with
cookies and everything.
I really love it.
So I'd love to show
you that if you--
JOHN DOLHUN: All right,
you convinced me, Barry.
BARRY KRIEGSMAN: OK.
JOHN DOLHUN: I'll go with milk--
BARRY KRIEGSMAN: OK, absolutely.
JOHN DOLHUN: --and cookies.
BARRY KRIEGSMAN: I'll give you
the cookies afterwards, yes.
So just take that
from me for a sec.
Here's your milk.
JOHN DOLHUN: Wait
a minute, Barry.
That was my $15
cabernet and it just
turned into a glass of milk.
[WHOOSH]
JESSICA HARROP: So Dr. Dolhun
wants milk for his cookies,
but all he has is wine.
So to go from wine to
milk, Barry pours the wine
into another glass.
This glass contains
barium chloride.
And barium chloride
dissolves in water,
forming barium 2
plus and 2 Cl minus.
Now, the barium 2 plus reacts
with the carbonate ions
in the original solution to
produce barium carbonate, which
is a solid white precipitate.
And, of course, the
solid white precipitate
makes it look like milk.
But is Dr. Dolhun
satisfied with milk?
Let's find out.
[WHOOSH]
JOHN DOLHUN: That
was my $15 cabernet.
And it just turned
into a glass of milk.
BARRY KRIEGSMAN: Oh,
sorry about that.
I thought you wanted the milk.
JOHN DOLHUN: Barry,
it's a bad deal.
Is this milk organic?
BARRY KRIEGSMAN: Uh, no.
[LAUGHTER]
JOHN DOLHUN: Barry, come on.
You you have to do
something for me.
BARRY KRIEGSMAN: OK, fine.
How about this?
I'll treat you.
I'll give you some beer.
It's on the house.
JOHN DOLHUN: Beer?
BARRY KRIEGSMAN: Yeah.
JOHN DOLHUN: Now you're talking.
BARRY KRIEGSMAN: As a little
substitute, a little pay,
you know, return for
messing up your order.
So just take that
from you right here.
JOHN DOLHUN: That is nice.
[APPLAUSE]
A beer with a frothy top on it.
BARRY KRIEGSMAN: Enjoy, enjoy.
[WHOOSH]
JESSICA HARROP: Finally, Barry
turns the milk into beer.
To do this, he adds some
hydrochloric acid to the mix.
Now this dissolves
the barium carbonate,
the solid white precipitate.
And this is the reaction.
So he adds the hydrochloric
acid, which breaks apart
the barium carbonate solid.
This yields barium, water, and
carbon dioxide gas is released.
And this H plus in
the reaction comes
from the hydrochloric acid.
To get the yellow
beer color, Barry
throws in some dichromate,
which is yellow.
And he puts a lump of solid
carbon dioxide or dry ice in it
to make it bubble.
So what did Dr. Dolhun
and Barry show us today?
They took a clear solution
with certain chemicals in it
that turns color, pink, when
another chemical is added,
then goes milky when
then goes clear again
when another is added,
and then goes yellow
and bubbles when
two more chemicals are added.
This shows us how
chemistry can be
used to program a system to
take on different observable
properties.
It's truly magical.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
That's it for me.
Hope you enjoyed the magic.